Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're looking back at the year
through the lens of our online purchases
because after all,
that's how we define
ourselves anyway, right?
That's how I do.
No, I..
This was a lot of fun
last year when we did it,
and I think that you,
you expand,
you've already pre-expanded,
'cause we said this would
be our Amazon purchases
because
I totally forgot that.
'Cause we get so many
things through Amazon.
So I've kinda limited
it to those purchases.
But I know you're going outside of that.
I had to.
And so I reserve the right
to maybe go outside of that a little bit,
'cause I did make some
significant purchases
that were not on Amazon.
But..
Whatever you need to
fully define yourself,
that's what this is about.
Well, you know, I..
'Cause if you,
Unless you buy things,
how do you know who you are?
Well, how do you know,
I've discovered that my
sort of calling in life
is to go into the driveway
and to break down boxes,
and flatten them.
Oh God.
And put them into recycling.
Like that's my me time
'cause I try to get my kids to do it,
and they won't, you know,
I'm a failed father.
'Cause I think,
Yeah, I think last year my list was
that special box cutter
which I'd recommended,
Yeah, yeah
and it was on my list.
We had to pick up something.
We had to pick up a mirror that wouldn't,
every time it was delivered
to the house, it was broken,
so Christi arranged for us
to pick it up from the shop.
And then we got there,
and I took my box cutter with me
'cause I'm like, I wanna open it there,
and I wanna do it with my box cutter.
And they were like, yeah, you
don't have to open it here
because then, well, you can't,
you have to turn in the packaging.
I was like, no, we're opening it here,
and I'm using my box cutter.
I could tell they were really eyeing it.
They liked the slice.
It was broken, by the way.
Your box cutter was broken?
No, the mirror was broke.
Oh.
And so we didn't,
we still didn't get it.
Mirrors break, man.
It's one of the hazards.
I'm not gonna go..
Better on their dime than ours.
I'm gonna go through a lot of stuff,
and more stuff than you, undoubtedly.
I'm going through everything I bought.
But I'm not going through
my exhaustive list
because that's 141 individual items,
Oh my gosh.
That are just for me
Now, I want you to understand,
the vast majority of these are
very small inconsequential,
and I'll get into some of those.
It would just be..
Why are you apologizing?
No, I'm just saying it'll be..
Well, because people are like,
people have lots of opinions
about buying stuff on
Amazon to begin with.
I get it, I understand.
I think in the end, we're
gonna figure this out,
and I think that the
convenience of the service
is gonna be something that we find
a way to do without qualm.
But I will say that
that comes out to like almost,
almost buying something
every other day, you know?
But, I'm buying multiple
things in one shipment,
but still, there ends
up being a lot of boxes.
So there's a little bit of guilt.
There's a little bit of
guilt associated with this.
I'm just saying that up front.
But I mean, the place I wanted to start,
just because there's literally,
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
eight items in just this one journey,
and this is just for me.
This doesn't count the
ones that Jessie got.
Oh, you're starting with...
I was gonna start with the journey.
Okay.
This is good.
Who's got the better journey?
It sounds like you've
got a longer journey.
Mine's simple.
Go for it.
And that is the journey
to acquire the correct face mask.
Oh, uh huh.
And this is something
that is especially...
The reason that this is so personal to me
is that it has to do
with the beard, right?
So early on in the pandemic,
when we started wearing masks a lot,
I started realizing that
I was getting mask beard,
and it can get so pronounced.
I don't know if you remember
when we were practicing
the livestream that day,
and we wore masks during
the livestream rehearsal.
Yeah.
And I took it off to show everybody
what my mask beard looks like.
Crazy.
And Paisley
got a profile shot of me, which we can,
Are you sure you wanna show that?
You know what, I'm not gonna show it.
No, it's being shown.
No, no I'm not showing it.
Already happening.
There is so many shots of me
out there without a beard.
I don't have to show the mask beard.
I don't have to do it.
I reserve the right to
not show the mask beard.
They already saw it.
They haven't seen it.
It's over.
I'm making the call.
We're not showing it.
You've really booked it up.
And they just saw it.
Oh, you know what?
You can tweet it on your personal account.
They're seeing it again.
Wow.
So because the mask...
And here's the thing about mask beard.
It's not just that the
mask beard looks bad.
It's that,
Oh, we can tell it looks bad.
We're looking at it a third time.
It locks in like you've
put a curling iron.
And like you can't get rid of it.
Unless you stop,
and you wash your beard with shampoo,
and then let it dry, like you can't,
You shampoo your beard?
Yeah.
I mean, in order to get...
When it's that locked in, it will not...
It's like you've curled your hair,
and you can't get rid of it.
It's like you don't have a beard.
You just have hair for
skin against your face.
And then there's a line,
and then there's something
hanging down there,
like a curtain.
Yeah, we're looking at it a fifth time.
So, the problem is,
is that they make these masks that are,
that are supposed to
cover your whole beard.
Yeah.
And I tried a few of these, man.
I'm gonna go through all the masks.
So I started with the Bio-th face mask.
This is just like that...
Makes kinda like a duck build.
It's an N95.
It's a disposable.
K95, yeah.
Yeah, K95.
K95, whatever it is.
Pointy.
And I was like, this is causing trouble.
So then I did the Mashele
XL Summer Face and Beard.
Summer face?
Head wear reusable cloth
covering for dust outdoors.
First of all, lots of cloth
masks early on in the pandemic,
before we really understood
that those are not very effective.
Yeah, but that was a whole year earlier.
Well, this is...
Well, I'm still...
No, but the cloth is not
really working that well.
That knowledge was
really dispensed in 2021.
It wasn't really dispensed in 2020.
When we all kinda came to
terms with the fact that,
I think it was more of
a 2021 thing for you
because you were of getting out.
We were becoming more active,
and needing masks more.
And trying to settle on like,
We bought a lot more masks
in 2021 than 2020.
What is my mask gonna be?
Right?
And this is before I was like, okay.
I'm still trying these masks
that are probably not even effective.
'Cause now you're making
a public decision.
Yeah.
Not just a protective decision.
There's a look here.
Then I did the Toltech's face mask,
then the Purian face mask adult XL,
extra large for men with beards.
Then the Craft and Soul Mattana face mask.
Then the EnerPlex Youth
Adult three Ply face.
Okay, so now I'm getting back into like...
This is a point where I abandoned...
I'm like, just trying
to cover the whole beard
is not a tight thing.
It's just, I'm not wearing a mask
just to make it look
like I'm wearing a mask,
which is what a lot of people do
who don't even believe
that the masks work,
even though they clearly do,
if they're worn right,
and it's the right kind of mask.
Some people are just like,
I'm complying with your
idea here, your rules,
but I'm trying to make
it as easy as possible.
But I was like, I actually,
I'm actually interested in
doing this in an effective way.
So I abandoned the beard mask
'cause it's just not gonna happen.
It's kinda like when you wear a hat,
you're not gonna then,
if you're out with people,
just take the hat off,
and then walk around with hat head.
You're committing.
You're just gonna have to
wear the mask all the time.
Right and then,
I got this Outdoor Research
Essential face mask kit.
A kit?
You build your own?
These are the words
that they use.
And then finally, I just landed
on disposable face masks.
And..
You gave up.
Yeah.
So now I operate with
two distinct choices.
There is the K95 or KN95, whatever it is,
which is what we have here at the studio
for everybody to wear.
That was on my list of something that I...
That's what we buy a lot of.
And that locks it in,
and that does give me mask beard.
And then I've got just a surgical mask,
like the 3-ply surgical mask,
which is effective at catching droplets.
But it sits more on top of the beard,
and doesn't create...
Like if I'm like, If I'm doing...
If Jessie and I are going out,
and we have to wear the
mask into the restaurant,
but then when we sit down,
we take the mask off to eat...
So it's kinda like,
we're wearing a mask just
to say that we wore a mask,
or just because they made us wear a mask,
and we went in.
I believe in masks,
but when you're going
in a restaurant to eat,
you're not really accomplishing anything
by wearing a mask as
you walk to your table.
Okay, I'm taking a risk at that point.
But in that case,
I don't wanna have mask beard on my date.
So then that's when I
just wear the surgical one
that sits right on top.
I can kinda deal with that mask beard.
Yeah.
But there an eight point-
You have a system.
There was an eight point mask journey,
and that didn't even include the stuff
that Jessie was buying.
It went all over the place.
Okay, my journey,
You wanna know my version of that journey,
is with garden hoses.
So on a much..
You were trying to watch
the virus off your face
with a garden hose?
Yeah.
'Cause I don't wear a mask,
but I wash my face every day.
Well, I will constantly...
I'm constantly blasting my
face with a garden hose.
The virus can't get in there.
You just go right in here,
and it comes right out your nose.
Turns out, it's really
hard to find a garden hose
that's worth a damn.
It's true, man.
I was looking back through the list,
and I was just so shocked.
I was like, okay, I got
an expandable garden hose,
'cause you don't want...
I don't want one that you got
to like loop up and you know,
all the problems with where
is it gonna be stored?
and how big is it?
and how un...
It just doesn't cooperate
with being coiled.
I went
on this journey in 2020, by the way.
Did you talk about it?
I don't think.
I don't know if I did, man.
Why didn't I...
Okay.
I went...
'Cause I bought it at the hardware store.
It was expandable.
And then what would happen is,
it was like black and it was scrunch up.
So the moment that all
the liquid came out of it,
it would shrink up like cold wiener.
Looks like a cold wiener.
And then it'd be
very easy to store.
But then when that thing gets plump again,
when it's shooting out all that water,
it's spurting out of every place.
It's cracking leaks all over the place.
Just like a penis.
And I will tell you, that like
we bought the ones that
said, "Oh, 100% guaranteed."
And then what are you supposed to do?
They break.
They don't just break.
Sometimes..
We bought three, and they were all like...
They just split in the middle.
And like oh, they're just all sectioned.
You can't get an expandable.
So then we were so angry
that we bought a flex steel.
Like we went to the opposite extreme.
It's like a chrome...
It's just a pipe.
It's just a pipe on a hinge.
You can't...
It doesn't bend at all.
It did bend.
It would bend up, but it was like..
This is not gonna leak.
No I can only water in this exact radius.
But it will never leak.
What we did and you know honestly,
Christi is the one who bought it,
its like Christi looked
at those leaky wieners,
and she said, "I'm going
medieval on your ass."
Like literally, I'm
buying the armored version
of a garden hose.
This is the one from the infomercial?
It's just called flex steel.
I think there's an infomercial for it.
Not Flex Seal.
That's an infomercial.
That's for the boats.
No, no, I know that's not..
When you wanna cut chop
a boat in half, and then,
'Cause there's also infomercials
for the expandable ones too.
That's where I fell in love with the idea.
And then we ended up with,
it's called a no kink,
but it's like it's made of
different stuff than expandable.
So it's kind of expandable.
Yeah, I can't go there.
It's called no kink.
You gotta go kink.
I gotta go kink.
So its still kinks.
Yeah.
Because listen,
Garden hoses suck.
You can't help but kink sometimes.
There is...
I mean, there's gotta be an answer,
and I still haven't found it.
I gave up with the third one.
It's not leaking yet,
but it is kinking,
even though it is called the no kink.
Well, I don't have a record of this,
'cause again, I went
to the hardware store,
'cause I do shop local, okay?
I believe in that.
I went to the hardware store to get...
We actually decided on a hose that is
not expandable per say,
but like it gets really...
It doesn't shrink up,
but it's super like flexible.
That's what we have.
And they're black.
Yes.
It's called the no kink.
Okay, well I've got...
We have..
That's what we have.
We have three of those,
or four of those
Maybe that works.
That are in the house
And I bought the things to wind it up.
Not the crank it wind it up,
but just this thing that sits
on the side of the house,
and we just roll it around.
Christi wants
to get a piece of pottery
that I can just shove it down.
Like a snake.
Like a decorative...
It's like a cobra coming
out of a piece of pottery.
You have to play an
instrument to get the snake,
to get the hose to come out.
That's the problem with that.
I can break
out my recorder.
We are dading so hard.
Move on to something else.
Okay.
Garden hoses, man.
Who would've thought.
Okay, now going in chronological order.
Again, this is just the stuff
that I thought was notable.
I bought this first thing because of you.
The NeilMed, special Link brand,
NeilMed Sinu Inhaler.
Sinu Inhaler.
What?
Natural, non-medicated,
aromatherapy inhaler.
So this is like...
Oh.
You come into the office,
and you got something
you put in your nose,
and you sniff.
It's a menthol stick, yeah.
I got it like two years ago, maybe three,
and the thing still works.
Yeah, it's amazing.
I used it a few seconds ago.
Didn't you see me?
So I'm not necessarily..
It looks like Chapstick
that you stow up your nose.
But I do find,
'cause I've got a
slightly deviated septum,
and the right nostril
will sometimes be like,
it's not really fully
functioning this morning.
It's got a little kink in it.
That NeilMed's gonna open you up.
And I,
I do that, and I keep it in my bag,
and I've used it probably a dozen times
over the past year,
and it was a really good purchase.
It's super inexpensive.
It's kinda like...
It makes you feel like you're awake.
But have you seen this new product?
It's all over the internet right now,
and if you're on TikTok or Instagram,
you're getting ads for it, if you're me.
It's called like,
like something drops,
like Wake Up Drops.
It's like..
I haven't seen this.
It's-
It's caffeinated?
No, no.
I think it's smelling salts.
I think it's essentially smelling salts.
It's a company that has
these things that you sniff.
Is it a..
And then you're like...
like It totally wakes you up.
I don't remember the name
of it, but everybody...
I'm getting a bunch of ads for it
'cause I guess they know
that I want that feeling.
It's probably toned down
from the ones that EMT's use.
I remember,
when my mom would always
get her EMT certification,
there was the smelling salts day,
and it's like a little pouch.
They would...
It's kinda like..
You can get them on Amazon.
I think when the policeman get trained
in how to use their tasers,
they get tased.
You can get tased,
and then smell it.
They line up,
and get tased.
Well, the EMTs lined up,
and they got smell salted.
And I was curious,
and I took one of the pouches,
and you burst it, and you sniff it.
And boy, that was an awakening.
Well, it works, man.
It totally works.
It was almost painful.
And I have to think this is
a lesser version of that,
because you're not knocked out.
Well, it doesn't knock you out.
It brings you back.
And if you..
But you don't use it
when you're knocked out.
You use it just when you feel like it.
If you just..
There's some people who swear
by smelling salts.
But you,
you haven't tried this.
You haven't tried this.
No, but some people
swear by smelling salts,
like before a workout.
It's a trend and so these
guys got in on that.
I'm interested in that.
You know that's akin to
the NeilMed menthol sucker.
But you know, the thing is,
you don't even use NeilMed brand.
Do you?
'Cause yours is not NeilMed.
It was bought for me and it lasts forever.
But it is smelled N-E-I-L,
so it a different family
Yeah, I know
what you're talking about.
We're gonna talk about more products.
But first..
We gotta sell you some products.
Were you talking about mythical.com?
Is that what we're talking about?
Last chance?
Gift cards.
What is it?
Oh, okay.
Oh, we've got gift cards?
Yes.
That's perfect for the
holiday season, Keko.
It's perfect.
You know, It's like you don't
know what to give somebody,
but you know that
they're a mythical beast,
so you give them a mythical
gift card.
Give them a
mythical gift card.
And then they can buy
whatever they want with it.
Am I right?
That's how gift cards work.
Yeah
And we have them.
We're selling them.
Where?
Mythical.com.
Of course.
I love it.
One of my favorite things
about this stage in my life
is that there are things happening.
That you take credit for.
Under the banner of the company
that we created, that we are told about.
That's a good place to be.
Yeah
Mythical smelling salts.
Seems like we're gonna have
to push hard for that one.
Yeah, i kissed an old man, I
think we could get into that.
The sniffalafagus.
Something Drops, like Horse Drops.
I can't remember what it is.
You got something else?
Suck and Wake.
We'll go back and forth.
We'll go back and forth
until you run out of things.
I got some smart plugs.
I committed to Wemo.
Not a sponsor.
None of this crap is a sponsor.
But you buy one smart plug,
and then all of a sudden you've got
all these other smart plugs, and then..
Explain this to me.
Is it...
Taps into your router?
Yeah,
and it's all in one app.
Expands?
You have smart lights in your house.
Yeah, but I don't have
no internet on them.
I do that with the Nest,
How?
With the Nest notes,
the Google Nest notes.
That's interesting.
Yeah, these,
they connect through your WiFi,
and then through your Google Home,
I control them, which is the same
thing you had.
Oh, it's not
expanding your wifi signal.
No, no, no.
No.
It's just a smart.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so the lights that you...
I went to...
I had a few of those,
and then we did a remodel,
and there's more lights on
the outside of our house,
and when the electricians came to do that,
I said, "I want all of my plugs."
So I guess I'm catching up with you.
Then you went Wemo.
Because I already had some Wemo.
But these Wemo were hardwired in.
So now..
Yeah, I do the Lutron on that.
And you know what I did?
I didn't get enough.
Like I still have...
Before I go to bed, there's one light,
I have to walk to the front of my house,
and turn off the chandelier
at the front door, manually.
Here's the thing,
I believe in having at
least one manual light,
just to stay grounded.
I feel like it's done that for me.
Yeah, there's one light that
you gotta actually touch.
But they were all..
Just one that doesn't even have a switch,
I have to unscrew the bulb every night,
just to feel grounded.
You just shoot it out with a BB gun.
Yeah, just put in another one.
In the morning.
Put it
in a new bulb.
Screw it, in the morning.
Take a little BB gun out there, shoot it.
You know somebody lives like that.
Justin Timberlake
apparently wears a new pair
of underwear every single day.
Really?
I saw that on one of those
Buzzfeed articles 10 years ago.
I mean, once you start adding
the smart light switches
to your cart for every light switch,
that puts a pounding on your,
That's a big cart.
On your pay,
on your wallet.
Yeah.
So I just got,
I got purchase fright.
So I was really excited,
and then I didn't get all
the ones that I needed.
Well, you can always just get more.
Yeah, but then..
But then you gotta get
somebody to install them.
They say you can do it yourself, but..
Yeah, you can't.
But it doesn't have my...
It's not a Neil...
It doesn't say NeilMed on it.
You know what I'm saying?
I know how to put something
up my nose and breathe.
This is not something you just smell.
Therefore, this is...
This requires some electrical knowledge.
If you gotta...
If you've gotta go to your power panel,
and turn off the power
before you do something,
Yeah, that's not happening.
That's a red flag
for me being involved.
I'm making a call on that one.
You know?
It's like if you're just gonna
kill everything in the house,
well then I gotta restart everything.
I believe you also got one of these.
I don't know if you got the same brand.
I actually had to go through two,
and then I landed on this one.
The Geesta Grill Press
Steak Weight Burger Smasher,
with wood handle.
You stealing my thunder, man.
All the stuff you've gotten..
When did...
You got that earlier in the year?
You didn't tell me.
No, I told you about,
I forgot.
Like I was on a quest for
the perfect smash burger
because it's what my kids
really really like, you know
Yeah, me too.
I like a smash burger,
and a thick burger, but..
I totally...
My family only likes..
So this happened earlier
in the year.
Yeah, this is like January.
And you told me about it.
I totally forgot.
Well at the end of, I
think at the end of 2020,
I may have even talked about it last year.
I got one, but it wasn't completely flat.
It was like it had a ring on it,
and it had enough for the burger
to kinda sneak up in there,
and you couldn't..
Yes.
So I was like, this is no good.
I want one that I can just smash it
as thin as I possibly can.
As I want it.
Right, and when I was...
I didn't access this conversation because,
yeah, it was three months ago,
I went and got my burger smasher set.
You got a set?
I got a...
First of all, for my Green Egg grill,
I got the half moon griddle,
Yeah
So that I could smash the...
You can't do that on the grates.
Yeah, I do it inside in a pan.
And then, yeah, so you
gotta get the smasher,
and you're right.
It cannot have a lip because then...
Yeah, you want it to be smashed out,
and for the edges to be uneven.
You don't want it to be a perfect circle.
Yeah, yeah
And you gotta have the
right amount of meat,
and you got to measure it out.
That's dumb.
You gotta really watch out for that.
That's the hottest tip I think
people are gonna get today,
from Rhett and Link,
is your burger smasher cannot have a lip.
Yeah
And half of them on Amazon,
even highly rated ones, do.
Yeah, it actually was..
And you know
what else you need to get?
But what did you...
'Cause I went with a Geesta.
I like it 'cause it had a wood handle.
I didn't even put the name brand down,
but it wasn't...
Mine's fully metal.
There's no wood because wood gets stained.
It looks nicer.
Wood keeps the heat from
coming into your hand.
I also do recommend wearing gloves
'cause it'll burn the back of your..
Oh, yeah.
It'll burn all the
hairs off your knuckles.
I've had some...
In fact, it makes me want
to do that this week.
I've had some really good burger times.
You gotta get the smash right,
but then this is why I got the kit,
because you also have
to have a shaker ready
with everything you need.
So like you smash, and
then you shake on your,
your salt and pepper or
whatever your mixture is.
Definitely needs...
You want it to be salty.
And then when you flip it,
you flip it, and you salt.
You shake it again.
So you gotta, you got
to have a smasher hand,
and a shaker hand.
And the grill is so hot
that I gotta do it fast.
So I've got a shaker that's big.
It's not like...
You can't shake on something,
then shake on something else.
You gotta have one shaker
that has everything,
like the deli style.
And it's pretty big.
So it's like a three inch diameter
You gotta get your ratios right
if you do that.
But then you're shaking kind of..
I'm just doing mostly salt,
and a little bit of pepper.
Yeah
And I might put a little garlic powder..
A little bit.
In the meat, before I mix it.
But you...
With my grill and with
the timing and everything,
and they grill so fast,
I can't regulate it like a stove top.
So it's like, if it gets really hot,
you just gotta be fast.
So I don't have time to
be shaking two things.
Well, that's the other thing too.
I mean, it's cool to be outside and do it,
but I've actually...
And I've got a nice smoker slash grill
that I use for a lot of things.
But I have transitioned
to burgers and steaks
inside, man.
I'm doing burgers and steaks inside.
I'm doing steak in a
pan, you know because...
If you go to a fine steakhouse..
Yeah, I just wanna,
It's got a grill in there.
I just wanna be able
to use the grill.
They're like, they're doing it on a...
Well, they're doing a broiler.
There's a challenge to it.
I'm not great at it
'cause there is timing.
The third thing in the kit
is an extra wide spatula
because when you smash that burger down,
Yeah
and it gets...
I like to make them really wide.
And then you gotta have
a real strong spatch
that you can just throw
underneath that thing,
and flip it real fast.
And then you cheese them
on the grill, right?
Cheese them on the grill.
And the other thing they'll
try to sell you in a kit
that I opted out of is a cover.
You don't need that.
Which then you can...
To help steam.
Like you put the...
You flip it, salt it,
put the cheese on it,
and then put a cover on it
to like really help it melt.
But I opted out of that
Unnecessary
I thought it was unnecessary
Okay
I'll never get smasher burger
Oh, were going about a year
Already?
'Cause that was me
I said, I sorted that
your smash was only a smasher.
Yeah
You didn't even have the other stuff.
And then I said yeah, I got the same thing
I mean, yeah, I already had
the spatula and stuff which is
I'll go again
I gotta whole category of stuff.
Okay
Related to the cat.
Its like you get another
type of animal in the house.
Like getting as second dog was one thing,
but like getting Saka in the house
and then coming to grips with
all the stuff that we needed to do
its like okay, now there's that
chair that he always sits in
there's hair all over that thing.
And then Christi is like
scratching it with her finger nails
like there has to be a way
so we got the ChomChom,
which is like a, its
basically like a lent roller
that then it creates a cat hair log
that you open the back of it
and this big log of cat hair comes out.
And you feed that to your dogs?
And then you feed that to the dogs.
No you just feed the cat
shit to the dogs apparently
Yeah right.
Which brings me to the other thing,
which is multiple litter boxes
Yeah
You know, its like we had just
the open cover litter box.
If you're a member of the Mythical Society
and you come to our monthly AMAs
you've heard me regail the story of
I'll tell it, go large
hear on Ear Bisquits.
Jabe is not into this,
but Jasper loves to eat that cat did he?
Gosh its so gross.
I'm embarrassed that I've
got something in my house
that can't help but eat cat shit.
Like, I don't know what it says about me
but I feel like it says something about me
that I didn't wanna be.
But if you had to use
one being in you house
to eat the shit of another
being in your house
you'd probably pick the animals
Yes.
And you'd probably go,
cat eat dog eats cat shit.
That makes me feel better about it.
So we're like trying to
get a type of litter box
that Saka will still use, but
that Jasper can't get into
and we went through..
We gotta big bucket type
that like he crawls down
inside of it and then that was working,
until we noticed that every
time I would go upstairs,
into my walking closet in my bedroom,
that I would smell, I smelt something
that I described as, like, a meaty smell.
Oh Gosh
I was like, is there something that like,
have I worked out and
lost a piece of clothing
that has gotten something growing on it?
That's like its the very deep dark smell
Meaty?
That's almost meaty, but like gross meaty.
And then Christi discovered
that the duffel bag underneath
all of my hanging clothes
in my section of the closet,
has been the depository
of Saka's pee, not dukey.
Saka has been crawling into that thing
and just peeing into my duffel bag,
again and again and again.
And we basically traced
that to stress related
to Lily leaving for college
and him not being happy about that.
I peed in a duffel bag when I was sad.
So then we had clean all that out
and we had to but this
angry orange detergent,
deterent is the word
You didn't keep that duffel bag?
No we got rid of the duffel bag
But you used some orange
deterent on the duffel bag
I now keep my gym clothes on it
No we heard about angry orange deterent
to spray on everything that the cat
wasn't supposed to be in peeing on.
Yeah and then so we sprayed in the area
that the duffel bag used to be
and then was very diligent
about closing our door
but then..
Is that why you smell like
orange juice in that shit now
Yeah like meaty cat pee
Yeah.
But what we thought was,
that he wasn't using his litter box
but was instead using my duffel bag,
was because he got too
big for the litter box.
So now I have this whole
purchase history of like
buying a bigger litter box
that he can jump inside
but then he still didn't wanna use that.
And then when we switched
to a bigger litter box,
that he can crawl in the side of,
thats when Jasper
started eating his dukey.
And so its like one problem
leads to another problem.
So now I'm on the verge of
buying kitty a litter box
that is robotic that,
Every time Jasper comes
up I just, scold him
Every time the cat poops it scrapes it up
and puts it in a place
but then its like, I don't
know the maintenance of that.
I don't know, there's a
lot of questions there
Yeah but you're already talking about
how if Lily really decides to take the cat
with her next year, that
you're gonna be sad.
Are you gonna fight for this cat?
This conversation has
given me a new perspective.
Because I'm also looking like
we bought a calming diffuser
that emits the feromones
that a mama cat puts out
to make the baby cats
not fight with each other
that also makes cats chill out.
So its like we're trying to
deal with the cat's stress
so that, and it also attracts the cat
to the area where we want the cat to pee
and not in the duffel bag
that's no longer there.
So there's that
Multiple litter boxes,
orange stuff
calming diffuser
chomchom hair thing and a litter genie,
which is like a fancy thing that,
as soon as the cat craps, you gotta,
we scoop up the crap
and put it in the thing
that then it puts it,
its like a diaper genie but for cat shit.
So we got, I like that
I recommend that.
You didn't use the robotic one
Haven't gone there yet
Okay
They're really pricey
and I'm also very skeptical if Saka
is going to go for it
or then if he's gonna start
shitting in the plants
again, which was the first problem we had.
Well I don't have any
cat related purchases
I did however, buy 40 large pinky mice
What?
Oh, you're talking about food for a snake
Yeah
Do you still have that snake?
Yeah, I mean, he's still
a part of the family
Moose, the snake
You about 40 at a time, you said?
He eats 40 at a time
No, he eats like one a week,
is shepherd keeps up with it.
Yeah so I have like a hand full of mice
in the freezer, which
Jessie isn't happy about
but its in, they're in a bag
that's in another bag.
You know, there's other animal parts
in our fridge that we eat.
Its not that big of a deal.
I mean you gotta,
why don't you put It in
the fridge in the garage?
It is in the fridge in the garage
Okay that's better
I'll run that off with a couple here
"Sex Criminals Volume One"
"One Weird Trick"
What?
This is a graphic novel
How graphic?
"Sex criminals"
This is a series
about a woman who discovers
that when she has an orgasm,
that time essentially stops
in the after glow.
And then she meets a man
who, after he orgasms,
the same thing happens
and they can interact
with each other and do
things in the afterglow.
This are famous graphic novel comic series
What were you googling
that you discovered this?
I was googling..
Can I stop time with my orgasm?
Yeah
why does it feel like
time has stopped after..
I was googling highly
rated graphic novels.
For a reason, for no reason at all.
And so, and I ended up buying
this one in a few hours
I think you misinterpreted
the adjective graphic.
Its actually not that graphic.
Its very funny
and its very well done.
I didn't actually, I haven't
even moved beyond volume one
not 'cause I don't want to,
but because I feel like I
learned what I needed to learn
for the purposes that I
was trying to learn them.
What occasions sitting down
to enjoy, what's it called?
Sex crime..
"Sex criminals volume one"
volume one
"One weird trick"
Like is this like a, before bed reading
is this like, downstairs by the fireplace
I don't do any reading
next to the fireplace
that only happens in movies man.
I mean you got a really
great place to do some...
I bought it for research purposes.
And I just read it in a couple of nights
like a couple of nights I was like okay
Dude, I don't know what
you trying to research
but you're not gonna
stop time by ejaculating.
You know what, Link I've tried
I do recommend that,
I don't know if that's gonna be my wreck,
I'm gonna pick one of this
things to be my official wreck,
but that was sort of a
weird one that stood out
when I was like, what did I buy..
Oh I know why I bought that.
And I bought a couple of other ones
that are like really well respected,
so its like time list graphic novels
that I actually can't remember
what they are at this point.
Nothing has been as good
as "Watchman" to me.
I'm a normy when it
comes to graphic novels.
Can I borrow it?
Yeah sure, just put it under you mattress
like when Train gave me that penthouse.
What I'm I going for next?
I'm gonna go with my biggest
purchase of the year.
Oh well, I think, yeah, my
next purchase ties in with that
so you go ahead and I'll..
No, no I don't think it does.
My mountain bike
Oh yeah yeah yeah
I got a new mountain bike
I mean this is probably my
biggest purchase since I got car
Sure has been
'Cause, you know one of the main things
that I got back into, year before last,
was my mountain biking.
You know I had fallen out of it.
Nick and I would go mountain biking a lot
and then it was just like, things got busy
and its kinda like surfing for us
its just like, it requires like,
some logistics umpth to get going with it.
And I got back into it,
and he got a new bike
like he upgraded to a full suspension bike
instead of just the front suspension.
And it has a fancy spring at it
and then he's talking
about how much better it is
when you know he's got
the adjustable seat post
where its like you just hit the button
and it adjust up and down
Yeah
And he's like talking about
how much more of an advantage he has
when going down hill with
his center of gravity
being able to be lower
and here I am, every time
we're about to do a big climb,
I'm getting off my bike
and I'm putting my seat up
high to get, you know,
'cause you wanna climb with the seat high
and then you wanna, then when
we're about to go down a hill
The writing was on the wall
Its like he's about, there he goes
and I'm getting off my bike
and putting my seat post all the way down
so that my center of gravity is lower
and I'm not going over my handle bars.
Right
And I'm like, you know what?
For my birthday, I'm gonna upgrade.
And you know, saved
thousands and thousands
like stuffs over $5000 for a bicycle,
it just seems like madness.
But if you want one that's gonna...
I mean this is like your life is in
This is some, there's a lot of engineering
that goes into this, its pretty amazing
You can't really get away...
You can't, especially if
you're going with someone
who has that type of equipment
Right
Who's made that investment
All those things he was telling me
he was like, he was selling me on it
and it took a long time.
And then with all the
supply chain things that
well happened and continued to happen,
I had my eye on a bike
that was, you, not even
available for pre-order.
But it was the one that I wanted
and I was just like, okay,
in three weeks, you sign
it for the mailing list
we'll tell you in three
weeks when this thing
is gonna become available.
And in three weeks, its
like, three more weeks
and then this happens for
like three, four months
Yeah
And then one day, we're riding
and I'm just, you know I'm telling him
and he's dude there's a
bike shop right over here
and they've got some in stock.
And I'm like, its funny how I just like,
I just like, I just cringe inside
I'm like, oh no, you mean
we're gonna go somewhere
right now and I'm gonna,
imma drop six grand on a bike
just right there?
Like this is, this goes against
every fiber of my being.
But I had made a decision
that I was gonna get a bike.
I had picked it out, and I
had spent the money in my mind
so it kinda helped me and I
went there and I was like,
you know what?
I'm never gonna get the other one.
So I ended up getting the specialized bike
Then you get to ride it
Yeah I get to actually ride it
I'd probably still be
waiting for the other one,
from Kenya.
So I got it specialized,
the tube at the bottom is a little bigger
and it has a secret compartment in it,
where instead of like a
bythes as an accessory
that go under your bike seat to hold like
your other bike tubes
and all that other crap
that you need if something goes wrong.
all of that stuff can be hidden
inside of the bike itself
Yeah
So I, that was cool.
And that got me a little bit excited.
It better be cool
I'm telling you.
So I got that thing,
and I've really been enjoying it.
Its made a huge difference,
having the full suspension.
Like I've never dropped that money
and then not, my immediate
experience was not just regret.
Like with all of the
psychology of me spending money
like that was one that I..
I've been so happy with it
in the past 6 days I've
gone out every other day
I'm like a pretty long rag.
Just by yourself?
Yeah, I've tried to go out...
I've got a shorter route
that I can do in like..
I can be from my house and back
in like an hour in ten.
So I can do like a 45-minute ride
and then I've got a good local ride
that's like two hours, that I can do.
So its like, an hour and a half climb,
and then its a really long
40-minute descend back down
and the thing that happens is
that neccessitates a
lot of other purchases
because you start going a little faster
and you've got more performance
and you've got, you start pushing yourself
and so I start falling off my bike more.
So its like oint medicine
Yeah
Manageist
Well, protective gear, so like
I got knee pads.
I've got elbow pads,
and I've still got all
these bruises on my thighs
and I fell off..
You need thigh pads
I fell off a few days ago and I hit my hip
and so now the last thing I
bought was padded underwear.
So I'm trying that.
You need one of those air
bags that if you fall off
the whole thing just inflates
and you become the michigan man
as you roll down the mountain.
I mean, these mountains that I'm on
its like, I mean, its treturous
One wrong move, and I'm
not telling Christi this,
buy yeah I could just crin
off the mountain and die.
Yeah
You know my..
But I'm pretty good
I enjoy mountain biking a little bit
like when Nick was getting
into it back in the day,
Yeah
And then like three of us went
out like a couple of times,
there was like, one time
I was coming down the hill
and I was like, the whole
time I'm feeling like
I'm going to go over the
top of the handle bars.
And I look around at
everyone else doing this
and I'm like no one is big as me
and that was like
It's tough
You know what?
I'm missing something out, I'm
gonna have to just say no to
because, yeah I'm too
worried about my body.
At times were more intense
than the stuff we do now.
We had no business being in
some of those places we were
especially on the bikes we were on
My bike's like 15 years old, 20
Oh God.
So, I mean so I got the protective gear
and then I'm like pushing
myself and coming back
and I'm having these headaches
that I can't get rid of
and I'm realizing I'm burning
so much , so many calories
and I'm not eating enough
and so it like leads to
figuring so many stuff out
and like optimization type stuff.
But then also, realizing oh I gotta be..
I can't just be drinking water,
I gotta be drinking some electrolytes.
So I start buying
the Tim Fares sponsored
element salty stuff,
you can get all types
he's not a sponsor of ours but like...
So now I put up a packet
of that into my...
I've gone to a point now,
where if I do like a two hour ride
or I push it
I'm either barely or
not getting a headache
between like calories afterward
and like drinking enough
electrolytes, I think
You're not feeling yourself in that
I'm kinda..
For the first time, its
kinda got me to a point where
I'm feeling almost athletic.
Almost athletic?
You know I've never
considered myself an athlete,
but like, I think this is something...
There's older guys out in this trails
and I think this could be me.
I think this could be a long
term version of golf for me.
As long as I don't kill myself doing it.
You're not gonna die golfing,
that's for sure.
But I kinda feel like,
I could be in the best shape of my life
if I keep this up.
Because I actually enjoy it.
Like I've never done anything
that's pushed my body so hard
that I've actually liked
because, I mean, there's
a physical challenge of it
but then there's, I mean
there's the mental acquility
of just the constant
reacting to the trail.
You know, so I think its good for my brain
and my body.
Yeah
And I feel like, I'm doing
something that requires
a lot of padding and
that kinda makes me feel
a little bit cool
You could probably like, slip into like,
in a real football game.
I mean the guys dress weird but
position as he play
Right
So a lot of crap related to that bike
Well okay, this is related
to a purchase that you made
which, this was unusual
because a lot of times
I'll decide to buy something
That's right
that then you'll get into.
And then this will work the other way.
So the purchase I have related to this is
again 'cause I'm limiting my Amazon
Okay
Is wrist cards with palm protection.
And this is when we..
This is a sore subject
We got the one wheels
you know, we've talked
about the one wheels
you know its that thing
that looks like a skateboard
but it's got one big wheel in the middle
Its electric,
so its pretty damn cool because its..
It kinda works like..
I have to think its the technology of,
what are those, the trendy things that..
The air boards.
It looks like a segway,
for lack of a better..
Its essentially, the wheel
itself is the thing that is
both propelling you and holding you up
and then balancing you.
And it has vagina tip charging
Yeah
and I mean,
And on the website when
you look at this thing
you like, you can go on dark trails.
Its not just for pavement
And some of the most fun that we..
I mean, so you got three of them, right?
No I got
No you got two of them
I got two because I kept seeing
this Instagram ads for them.
Yeah
And I was like, I'm trying to get the boys
out of the house and like I couldn't,
I haven't had luck getting them
to ride bikes that much with me,
because I end up pushing
things a little too far
and then they're just dejected.
And spent.
So that didn't take and I was like,
this will be fun
Yeah, 'cause its
And its not dangerous
You're not really working too hard on this
Yeah
There's some balance happening but...
Its not dangerous once
you learn how to do it
I mean, we're not gonna be
going off on this trails
but I kinda secretly hope
that we'll be going off
on these trails.
Right
And so then I'm like,
I get it and the I invite you
and Shepherd over to test it out.
And like Shepherd immediately took to it
so then, you're like I'm gonna
get a couple of this too.
So like yeah, I had the Pint for Landon,
which is a smaller one
and then the GT for me, the bigger one
Oh that XR
The XR
Yeah
And the you bought two XRs
Right
For, I mean they are not cheap
It was like $1700 for an XR
Very expensive
And maybe $1200 for a Pint
Or maybe more than that
They're one of the more..
They're pricier, like Evs, but I gotta say
you know, its same thing with Shepherd.
Its not easy to get Shepherd
outside of the house,
away from video games,
but any time I'm like,
hey lets go one wheeling
he says all right, he stops
what he's doing and we go.
And we have gotten..
Like we have found so
many cool places to go
where the majority of what
we're doing is off road.
And I've had some close calls,
I posted that one on my
Instagram where I fell
and messed my knee up,
and it actually wasn't that bad.
It was the worst fall that I
had because I actually fell
Well it was interesting I think
because even before that happened,
I was riding, you came over
and then you got me
and then you started riding
and then you start telling me about how
the type of injuries you
can get on this stuff
and how the dangers associated with it.
And I didn't, I had not
looked into any of that
I was like, wait you know,
we're just gonna be safe.
You know the nose diving
is the thing that..
Like if you start looking like YouTube,
everyone's got a story about,
"oh I broke my collar bone"
I think like Hezzy Nightstar
broke his collarbone
or broke something doing..
'Cause what happens is,
if you're comfortable
you get going real fast
and then it gets to a certain speed..
You go at 17 to 20 miles an hour
And then it starts,
pushes back a little bit
to tell you, hey, we
can't keep holding you up
at this speed
but if you ignore that it will nose dive
and then you immediately
just carine off that thing.
So I kinda stay away from that top speed.
Yeah you have to learn it.
You have to learn the limits of it
and you have to wear protective gear
if you're gonna be..
That was the one thing
is especially the risk guards.
'Cause the one time I
did fall on the pavement
I did nose dive, but its
only because I'm so big
and I'm like at the upper weight limit
and I was going up a hill
as fast as I possibly could
when it didn't feel fast
to me, it was just..
And I also couldn't feel the pushback
and nose dived or nose dove,
whatever the proper term is,
and I fell and caught
myself with my wrist guards
and it like skinned them up real bad
and I'm like, man, I
would've been real bad
if I hadn't had this wrist guards.
Then what happened
which brings me to
You never borrow any wrist guards
But I had to borrow your XR for Lincon
so that Landon could ride the Pint
and he and I would each have one.
And so I also took your
wrist guards that day
and then of course they
were always wearing helmets
and I had elbow pads and knee pads
from mountain biking
that I put on the boys.
Lincon had fallen and hurt
his elbow without pads
so I was like you gotta
wear the pads from now on.
And then I saw the wrist guards
and Landon was over there somewhere,
I told the story on go Mythical more
and so I was like well, I
got this pair of wrist guards
Lincon put these on.
Well, turns out I put the
only pair of wrist guards
that I borrowed from you on the wrong kid.
Yeah
And yeah, Landon, we were going off road
and Landon was getting pretty good at it
and then he just got tossed.
I saw it all happen.
And he said he hurt his wrist
and I said, you know, just like
just wait a bit and we'll walk back
Wave it off
And then we took the dogs
out for a walk later.
He didn't seem like he
was complaining too much.
I took him out to dinner later.
He said he was having
trouble using his hand
to get the food on his folk
Yeah
He's having to use the other hand.
And then his mum came home
from whatever she was at,
late after Landon was in bed.
His mom, your wife?
Yeah.
And then the next morning,
we wake up to Landon
by the bed telling his mom,
how much his wrist hurts.
And I didn't tell her
anything had happened.
So that's how she found out that..
And she was like you need
to take her to urgent care
and get him an X-RAY, which I did.
And when the nurse came back in,
I was pretty, you know I get
nauseous and uncomfortable
about potential breaks
and talks of circulation
and things of that nature.
Talk of circulation
So when the nurse comes
Its pretty broad
Comes in and says, yeah,
we took a look at the X-RAY
and his wrist is, just
above his wrist it is
broken clean in two, I started laughing.
Yeah, every good father would
But it was because I was
so uncomfortable that's...
I just like, I can't,
that's just the noise
that comes out of me.
And I didn't remember this,
but that's just what
Landon told me afterward,
when he also told Christi
His mom
Yeah.
He said that, you know,
that the nurse said,
"Sir, this is serious issue,
this is not a laughing matter"
I had a talk of circulation
And I was laughing so much
I was laughing so much uncomfortable
that I didn't hear her say that
I just kept, kinda giggling.
So yeah, he had a broken
wrist and at this point,
he's still not released by the doctor
to get back on the one wheel.
But when he does, he's got wrist guards.
So he didn't go the other day
its just you and Lincon
that went the other day.
Yeah.
Me and Shepherd went the other day
it had like the best time
that we've had
I love it.
Lincon and I had the best
time going to the same place
Well and then,
funny thing
going on like
sandy trails off road and like,
especially when you've
got the proper protection
wrist guards, elbow guards,
knee guards, helmets.
Well for me
you have confidence
The great thing about the off roading is,
you don't get as fast as
you do on the pavement.
So I actually feel,
like I follow a lot more
I fall off and then I
just kind of run it out
whereas when I'm on
pavement, I get so fast
I'm like, if I fall right
now, it's gonna be on pavement
and that's gonna be bad.
And then the funny thing
is, you've actually..
I think you've changed quite a bit
because, you know I saw the
advertisements for the new,
the new ones, the GT and the Pint.
The new Pint.
And it was like, this new one
the GT has more twork, more power
and like that's what I need.
Oh, it has the treaded
tyre that you can get,
oh that's what I need.
Yeah
Because I get on this
trails and I'm just..
I get to this hills that
don't seem that steep
and Shepherd, you know,
weighs half as much as me
he just goes right up,
I get on them and I just bottoms out,
like it can't support me, I'm too big.
And so, and then I tell you about it,
oh you already bought one
I got one coming.
I'm like what?
This man has gotten so loose with his cash
Listen, yeah,
I blame myself for the
accidents that my kids have had.
'Cause I, I'm getting another one.
This is fun.
Well and then what..
And I was like, okay,
well I gotta get one now.
So I got one of those and I'm like,
We got them on order
We're gonna have six of those things
we've got to like find a friend
to just come along with us.
You know the app, the app will tell you
if other people in the
neighborhood have it.
You can meet up with strangers in one way.
Yeah, I don't wanna do that.
Okay let me ride off,
a few quick ones here.
I got the Rapsador Mobile Launch Monitor,
which is a way to keep up with how
far your golf ball will go.
All you do is hit it in a net
and its reading the speed of the golf ball
and figuring out like oh,
you hit a six on this far.
Oh it doesn't say, oh you just
hit a three foot into a net
Yeah it tells you how
far it would've gone.
I gotta say I've had to back off of the,
I purposely haven't swung a
golf club in about two months
because I was convinced that
it was causing my shoulder
problem and unfortunately
I think I was right.
So I don't know..
I'm having to re-evaluate
my long-term future
Oh did you get into mountain biking?
Yeah, what I'm I gonna do?
If I'm hurting myself golfing,
what I'm I gonna do next.
Mountain biking
You know what?
This is gonna be my recommendation.
The Baseball Cap Carrier Case.
Okay you're like why do
you need one of those?
Okay so I was going...
Is this what it sounds like it is?
Its a way..
A plastic case?
Its a way to put baseball
hats in your luggage,
you don't have to worry
about packing them perfectly
Oh yeah
so that they
get messed up.
When I was going back to North
Carolina over the Summer,
I was gonna be playing golf
a few times with my dad
and my brother and I wear a
hat when I'm out in the sun
like that.
You need no one to be crinkled
But I don't wanna like,
I don't like having to then
wear the hat on the plane
and also there was like a
couple of hats that I had.
And I find this thing on Aamzon,
the baseball cap carrier
case and I'm like,
this thing is perfect
how was I, three to four baseball hats
and you just put it in your luggage
and you can't, I mean you
could step on this thing.
Is it hollow under the back
so you can still nest it on something
or does it take up a lot of room.
You know what I'm saying?
It takes up the room of a stack of hats.
It doesn't come and...
But where your head goes into the hat
is that hollowed out
No, no
in the case?
Its flat, the whole bottom is flat.
Which makes it easier..
It makes it easier to pack.
In some regard
It looks like it takes up
more space.
Well, maybe you can make one of those.
I don't wanna make one of those
in the Rosenbeck garden house.
Okay, I've got two items that I bought
because I have a 17 year old son.
I have one more by the way.
Oh you have one more?
Yeah
Okay, well I've got like..
I mean, I've got a few.
And I'm just gonna rattle through,
so if you wanna save yours for the last,
to be the last thing.
Okay
You have these two by the way.
Save it for the end, we'll
be united in our purchase
Okay, I share the blender with everyone
but the people who use
the blender in my house
is me and Loc to make these
protein shakes that we make.
And he doesn't clean up after himself.
And so he'll leave like some dirty..
Once you leave that blender
bottle out a few times
without cleaning it
Yap
It gets cloudy and nasty and
you'll never get rid of it.
Right
So what I decided to do is I was like,
I'm gonna buy a replacement
corough essentially
but I'm going to use that one,
and you're gonna keep using the crappy one
and you can do whatever
you want to do to it.
So now I have this blend tech corough
Which you've hidden
I keep it on the top
shelf inside a cabinet
and I literally, I use
it, I make my smoothie,
I wash it out immediately
yeah yeah immediately
I put it back there.
You could use it as glasses.
Its so clear compared to the other one
that looks like its painted.
This is a 70
I'm picturing you reading
through a picture..
What are you doing?
Are you looking at that
blend tech corough?
No I'm reading.
And I also got a three pack
of extra large shaker bottles.
Congratulations
You know what I'm saying because again,
same thing, he uses my shaker bottle
and I've got one, its
like, the green one is mine
I'll be like, where's my damn..
What is a shaker bottle?
I don't know what you mean.
Its like a..
Shaking what?
If you wanted to put a protein shake
without using the blender
Oh okay.
Its what we put..
I mean we'll shake like
pre-workout or something in there
but we also
Okay
just put the shakes in there.
And you know how, I mean,
this is typical dad but like
you're getting on the stairs
and you make your smoothie
and then you look..
And then immediately I
just flip out, right?
Because I'm just like, I know
he just took my damn bottle
and its like
Yeah
Its just one of the things
You can't have your own
And so I go up there and its in his room
and its got crap in it and it smells like
something died inside of it.
Smells meaty?
Very meaty
and so I bought the three pack.
And I was like you
can't touch any of this.
And I have three, just in
case you end up touching one
I got two more behind it.
And I did this several times.
Lightning cable, three foot, three pack
Oh, good luck with that
And USB wall charger
with three inputs on it.
Yeah yeah
I don't know how many of these,
someone
Eats them
Someone is taking them
and making like spaghetti out
of them somewhere in our home.
'Cause I was like, can't we just have..
Like I want one kinda
like, oh here's a charger
You're moving towards
just having your own house
Yeah, that's I've thought of this
and then you got it like,
there's one that's like behind the couch
and has extra long cables
Yeah
So like hey I'm watching TV
and my phone is about to die
I plug it in, shut it down.
Here's one downstairs in the
gym where we're working out.
Here's one in the kitchen just inacase..
I had it all figured out.
They end up taking them
and I just have to keep buying them.
I don't know what I'm gonna do about that,
I haven't solved that other
than just buying stuff.
This is one, I've spent a second on it.
I bought some tethers.
I noticed that.
I talked to Christi about it
Yeah
'Cause she has them
I was like, is this a thing..
Well, first of all,
somebody said that you're
supposed to say tethers.
I don't care.
I'm gonna say tethers because
that's what I've always said.
So..
Its the weariness
This is very funny that
you're bringing this up
'cause we haven't talked about this.
So, I can't remember where I was,
I think its when we ran keywest
and I like had my flip flops
and I'm thinking about the
fact that we're going to..
We're gonna spend some time
in mexico over the holidays.
And having like a shoe that
you can wear when you're like,
we're going and doing like
some outdoor activities
and I don't wanna wear
those like water shoes
that are like close-toed that we had,
remember like the ones that
we had and everybody got one
and we went to Figi.
I think you're talking about kins,
which are like the REI
version of like water shoes.
They're like closed,
I know what you're talking about.
I'm talking about the ones
that are more like sock-like.
Oh, well that, of course not
that's like..
And so I was like,
and so I have a bias of gifts
dumb child at a wave pool
type of situation
I have a bias against sandals
that are not flip flops, okay?
I don't like..
Jessie is like, you
need to get bucket socks
I'm like I don't like the
way bucket socks look.
And she was like you can
get some tether socks
I was like, I hate the way tethers look
like I've never seen somebody in tethers
Bucket socks are like hipy
but tethers are like granola
Right, but here's the thing,
I have a bias against them.
And I told Jessie, I was like,
if I get these, and I
wear these around Link,
it would be the first thing he
talks about when he sees me.
Its funny 'cause, there's
a clip going around about,
there's an interview with
Larry David from years ago
Oh yeah, the one that Simon
Folks says when he walks
in the room
he's gonna talk
about your shirt.
And me and you have
that kind of thing where
we've judged everything
that you could possibly wear
and we've come to a bunch
of conclusions about them.
Yeah
And so I think that tethers look dorky
I can't, I think they look dorky on me
I cannot get..
Whether you've got socks on or not.
When I put them on, and Jessie is like
you don't understand,
they're not dorky anymore
and if they are, that's
what makes them cool, right?
And so she's basically telling me this.
I put these tethers on one night,
we go to Pasedina
You went out
To go eat
and I'm walking around in these things.
And I've also got on like,
some like this cotton pants that like
a drawstring kinda thing, I
feel stupid the whole time.
But I'm feeling great.
Like I feel like I look
stupid, but I'm like
I keep this leaning on her like
I think I might be a tether guy.
Like this are incredible.
The fact that they don't flop,
they feel so secure but
my feet are breathing,
I'm like, I kinda think that regardless
of how this things look, maybe
I'm just a tether guy now.
Damn.
Christi wore these at
Disney Land both days
and here I am taking
off my shoes and socks
in a public place
Oh its revolutionary
And I was like, are
the straps kidding you?
No no no
She's like my feet are great
There's nothing,
it feels good the whole time.
I go into a coffee shop
Jessie is like lets get
a couple of decaffs.
I'm like, i'll go in, I
go in, I go to the counter
just some random coffee shop
on Colorado in Pasadena.
And the barista says,
hey, you look like you're from Colorado
She literally said that.
Yeah.
Of course he did.
I mean the hair, the beard
Yeah yeah yeah
and the tethers.
And so I was like,
Yeah the tethers wrapped
I was like, thank you.
I'm gonna take that as a compliment.
She says I love Colorado.
But I gotta say,
You know I'm from Colorado,
I just listen to my wife
I gotta say, that you're gonna be seeing
the tethers more often.
And I think that there is a
way to trascend in my mind
and like I'm kinda getting through this
sort of like, there's this sort
of like guys from the south
kinda bias that we have against..
We are thinking of
tethers in a certain way
that I'm just trying to let go of.
But me and you..
I know
We used to wear flip flops all the time
like on television, like commercial kings
we'd be walking around with...
No.
Yeah and also like
I know we didn't
get them anyway
And also like looking for Mrs.Waklare
were walking around with
flip flops and jeans
and its like, it looked horrible.
That looked horrible
Yeah
And we did it, we thought it was cool.
It kind of an anti
climatic ending down there.
I mean when I looked at you,
the only time I saw you wearing them,
you were in lounge wear at your own home
and I said you know what,
I'm not gonna judge a man for
what he wears in his own home.
Only if I didn't go out with them
So I didn't bring it up
But you thought about it.
I thought about them,
Yeah
But that's what I thought,
I'm not gonna judge a man
in his own home, you know
its like, I don't know what he's...
I don't know where this is going but..
I might be changing my rector Tevas
and Tevas if that's how you say it.
And you know what,
I mean after the Disney
Land air and out situation,
but now, we also have
this thing which is like
if you have a thing
we can't both have tethers
Now that can't be my thing.
Is it your thing?
And now I can't, are you boxing me out?
I got the tethers before you
But Christi got them before you
I mean my wife is really
pushing bucken socks.
And all these arguments
about bucken socks,
I thought bucken socks were
equally ugly,
I can't do it
I thought they were equally ugly,
but they were comfortable to me.
The tethers I feel like, I
can do anything, do anything
and now I've got this platform on my feet,
okay, we're about to run out of time
we actually have some place to be.
But I have to say,
The Continuous Water Mister
This is another graphic novel?
This is the follow up
of "The Sex Criminals"
No, its that thing, we
actually have one here
but I ended up getting one home
Mr continuous water
Its what I spray on my hair
to get it to bounce back
in for the curl to come back.
A lot of people are asking,
well what do you do?
Well you spray it with
a little bit of water.
What doesn't work, is wetting your hair,
the mister, and you know what?
You'll be like, I need
to hit my face with this,
its like, you know when you go to the park
and its really hot and you
want one of those misters,
Yeah
You can have one in your hand,
I highly recommend that.
Put any water in it?
Any water?
Yeah you fill it up with..
You can use tap water
if we have distilled water
on hand, I'll use that.
Okay, but its refillable
And the last thing, I'm actually
skipping over some stuff
just to spare you.
The last thing, I'll say,
we also have this here,
but I don't know what I
would do without it at home.
The downy wrinkle releaser.
The only reason I'm talking
about this is because,
the other day, when we
were in the wardrobe room
and getting ready for
GMM, and Stevie walks in
to ask her something, I'm like spraying
this thing directly on my clothes
and she looks at me and she's like,
you're spraying yourself with fabriz?
I know its not that bad.
She didn't know about the wrinkle release.
And so I feel like I just
have to tell the world that,
there's this spray,
that if your shirt is
a little bit wrinkly,
and you don't wanna steam it,
and you don't wanna iron it
how it works?
You just spray it lightly on it
and then just, the wrinkles go away.
You can get travel size, you know
you people who are breaking
out the ironing board
in your hotel room
I'm here in my Tevas just spraying myself
with water on my hair and
wrinkle release on my clothes.
I'm from Colorado.
See but were both, were plat boys today.
Neither one of us is their thing.
Its not yours or mine.
I think you can also wear tethers.
I think there's definitely
multiple situations.
There's probably whole
tethered families at Disney
that you just didn't, you
weren't thinking about it.
I wasn't .
The last thing I was gonna mention was,
The Aura Ring.
I didn't buy a lot of crap,
but that was a big thing
that in full disclosure,
we invested in Aura Ring
After buying it independently
and being satisfied with it.
Well you got this because, the
NBA players were wearing it
monitoring their heart rate
and their health and stuff
and all the COVID of it all,
but then its just like, all
the biometric measurements
in this ring are, they're more in depth
and more accurate than
the biometrics on my watch
that I also still enjoy
and wear because it..
And you can also try
I think
Yeah, Keko also got one
You got the Aura Ring you like it?
I love it.
Yeah we're investors
Yeah we, I just ordered
the next generation
which constantly monitors your heart rate,
not just while you're sleeping.
But I love the way that
it connects with the app
and it like tells you
what your readiness is,
and it kinda gives you
permission to take it easy
If you need to
Well they're saying that
the app will tell you
to do that
The reason that I love it is that,
it basically lasts like a week on a charge
whereas, I wear the apple
watch quite a bit but
like I'll get ready to go to bed, I'm like
man I gotta charge this
thing and then so..
Yeah
I mean, its technically four to seven days
the ring will hold the charge
and you would need to
charge it during the day
so that you could wear
it while you're sleeping.
But it also charges in like 30 minutes
Yeah it charges faster.
I used it this past week,
when I'm trying to make sure
like having something tell you
that you got all the sleep that you needed
and that this was the
nature of your sleep,
Yeah
For me, it gave me this like,
assurance that okay yes,
you're doing all you can
to keep from getting sick
as your family drops like flies.
The way it works with the app
and the way that it communicates with you
and optimizes your
exhautions and your resting
is..
I would say..
Is much more holistic
than with the watches
Your question about the tethers,
I mean two guys who are best friends
who both have a ring on their right hands
that looks pretty similar.
We have different models but
essentially its just like..
I think that that's probably more like,
those guys both have rings.
Now if we had the rings and
the tethers at the same time
And the plat
And the plat, I mean
And the beard
I mean listen, I'm heading towards..
Here's the deal, I'm not gonna
get rid of the beard, I cant
You're eventually gonna grow a beard,
I mean eventually at some point, right?
Yeah we know where this is going
I'm gonna get glasses at some point
I mean
We're becoming one person
Its gonna happen
We fought it and we're no longer caring so
it is actually going to happen
Yeah
So that's all the stuff that I bought,
and some of the stuff that Christi bought
that I took credit for.
And that's a third
Not even a third, that
was probably a tenth
but it was inconsequential like spirelina
and you know, I didn't
mention, that was one, you know
got some of that, got a whole bag of it.
Okay, #EarBiscuits
let us know what you think
about what we bought.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episodes of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this Podcast,
it is available on all your
favorite Podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.